um
lawrence you're in you are in texas
right now right
that's right all right well with that we
got to bring in texas congressman dan
crenshaw to help us out with some news
of the day good morning to you
congressman
hey good morning thanks for having me
you know congressman there's so much
going on right now with covid um a
shortage of testing a shortage of
monoclonal antibodies that i don't think
is getting enough attention um and for
the very first time ever president biden
is sort of washing his hands of this and
saying that there is no such thing as a
federal solution to all this what do you
make of the current state of things when
it comes to coven and covet rather in
president biden's recent remarks
yeah it's like he gets it backwards
there is a federal response to kovit
it's just not what he's doing so what
he's doing is imposing unconstitutional
mandates you know there's these ocean
mandates that would require businesses
to fire workers who aren't vaccinated
that's the opposite of what he should be
doing what he should be doing
is is is aiding our supply systems and
aiding our health care system so how do
you do that well president trump did it
by
engaging in operation warp speed by
creating a testing regime that was uh
really second to none by the time it was
up and going all biden had to do was
continue to those things continue
improving upon those things and he sort
of washed his hands of it and instead
tried to take this hammer to the
situation instead of the scalpel that
has been needed by the federal
government to actually get things going
you know in texas we are one of those
states that doesn't have these
monoclonal antibodies anymore we've run
out uh we've been complaining to the
administration about how these formulas
are
are distributed um when not just before
monoclonal antibodies but also for
vaccine distribution as well and so this
administration just hasn't had the
organizational wherewithal to really
deal with this and uh they're learning
the hard way that they probably owe the
trump administration an apology because
as i recall everybody called trump a
murderer just because there was a global
pandemic coming through it was the first
time we dealt with it
yeah it's amazing getting it just how
things can change so quickly you know
you're in congress you're sitting there
you're a texan but you're in dc it's
probably hard a little bit to see this
happening to the people you care about
and represent to not be able to go get a
test or or to just have an
administration seem lazy on the job what
can congress do what can you do as their
congressman now and i don't mean to
point it directly at you but what can
congress do
to help your constituents to maybe get
tests or feel better about this
well we'd love to be able to give you
better news but the reality is congress
has already appropriated tens of
billions of dollars to to this
specific problem right now it's a
management problem it's the executive
branch is not executing these dollars in
an efficient manner uh that's what's
going on and again look i'm a
conservative i i always
make sure people know there is only so
much government can do and the moment
that it starts doing more than it should
be doing you start to see unintended
second and third order consequences that
harbor everybody worse than you wanted
to so what the federal government should
be doing again using using their fema
resources to bolster a lot of these
testing sites open up new testing sites
this is what we saw happen during the
trump administration uh we should be
using our resources to increase those
supply chains to get those monoclonal
antibodies out to people faster and and
president biden announced this we just
haven't seen results from it um helping
us get more healthcare workers either
from the military or from fema um to to
aid in some of these hospitals that are
feeling a little bit overwhelmed it's
still worth noting that that at our
height of hospitalizations right now it
really doesn't even compare to the
heights that we had before in 2020 uh so
it's i don't want people to panic about
this but look take the same precautions
you've been taking for two years
yeah i think you're right because we got
to live with this we got to learn how to
protect the vulnerable um and and if we
do that i think we're going to be just
fine i want to shift to some uh foreign
policy news uh president biden is
expected to speak with
russian leader uh vladimir putin ahead
of the geneva uh talks so what should
the president project today uh it seems
like like
after that last chat that he had um
putin really didn't get the message he
sent more troops so uh what does he need
to do today
to project strength
so so president biden has to make clear
that there will be costs and
consequences to whatever putin does with
the ukraine now uh i think everybody
knows that we're not really willing to
send troops to the ukraine and fight the
russians in eastern europe uh for this
and there's a lot of people on our side
a lot of people commentating that that
uh that ever you know these these these
war mongers are just trying to get us
into war we'll just hold up a little bit
there's a lot of options in between
doing nothing and in between war
lots of options up there uh mostly
economic sanctions that's what president
biden has been talking about it seems he
needs to be a bit more specific and
maybe hit putin a little bit more
personally with his own finances if
there's going to actually successfully
deter the ukraine i think taking a page
out of the trump playbook would actually
work quite well here um what trump did
which was different than the obama
administration was actually give the
ukrainians defense weapons as opposed to
say logistical supplies and and that
kind of aid that sends a pretty clear
message to the russians that this fight
will not be as easy as you want it to be
it doesn't mean america is going to come
in
you know gunslinging going to war that's
that's not what this means at all what
it does mean is that there will be some
minimal amount of support that make the
cost too high for you to do this yeah
one of the more concerning headlines
today affects your home state of texas
in harris county
113 people charged with capital murder
so the most serious crime there is they
were
granted bond released back into the
community and some of them
re-offended
and when you're talking about 113 people
this isn't just a one-off this seems to
be the system that's in place what needs
to change here congressman
yeah and this was some great local
reporting done in my hometown which
which showed us what we what we already
knew that a lot of the crime being
committed is being committed by the same
exact people over and over and over
again they just get they just keep
getting released out on bail now for
violent offenders you really got to
scratch your head and wonder how that's
possible i mean these are people who are
being charged with capital murder and
then released on bond no problem left
out into the streets
and big surprise they actually commit
another murder and kill again
there are people who should be alive
right now were it not for these liberal
judges who who they operate off of this
false sense of compassion they think
they're doing the world a kindness of
some sorts by letting these criminals
get out but in the end they're they're
doing the opposite it's malevolent in
its nature because it goes they go out
and they hurt people they harm people
these are violent people there's a
reason we have a system the way we have
it this is happening not just in houston
of course this is the story across all
major american cities where you're
seeing murders spike the the bail reform
the the the false compassion of da's and
prosecutors that were funded by george
soros to be in those positions that is
the story of crime across america right
now the good news is for america we can
vote them out
da's judges in texas we vote for judges
we can vote them out and and get our
streets back
you talk about you talk about voting
them out i know that texas i lived in
texas for a little while for a couple
years and i think i'm 18 years from
being able to call myself a texan i was
told i had to be 20 years to claim the
title but when i was there i was around
austin and a lot of people were moving
in from southern california the tech
industry was there and i know texas like
where i'm at in georgia
the the the balance of power is kind of
evening out it's kind of 50 50. is that
is this a part of that is that why we're
seeing stuff like this happen in texas
or is this just kind of a a one-off
thing happening here and and i think
it's harris county
well yeah
you're somewhat correct i wouldn't
compare it to georgia just yet i think
it's still a lot redder than georgia has
become but uh it is the story of the
urban rural divide
where in urban areas it gets bluer and
bluer and bluer and the rural areas just
get redder and redder and and so it's
tougher and tougher in these in these
blue areas i mean houston
until recently was run by a republican
county judge harris county was a
republican county judge uh but that
changed recently and look at the
outcomes that we get because of that so
i think people are able to see past
their sort of jersey wearing here of the
red and the blue and just voting for
your team and see the consequences of
policy actions and i hope that remains
the case
yeah you're right congress is something
similar in dallas as well you know
dallas is run for by a lot of the
progressives but the suburbs outside of
dallas within the county uh they're more
red um so part of your efforts is to
keep texas red and that's a big issue in
our state so you got exclusives for fox
and friends you're gonna unveil texas
reloaded two
in an effort to keep texas ready we got
a little clip of it and then we'll have
you react congressman watch all right
yeah i'm gonna need another team
[Laughter]
so congressman you got yourself in there
obviously you got wesley hunt a veteran
as well as morgan latrell also another
veteran
that's right that's just a little teaser
for you we've got the we're still
working on the rest of the movie it's
going to be really cool and you can
support our efforts to do that by the
way at texasreloaded.com
that's where people can go and make sure
that we get this really cool ad up on tv
and get these two guys elected so
they're both running uh right there in
the houston area
for texas 38 and texas eight great guys
veterans wesley hansa former apache
pilot west point grad morgan latrell is
a seal for 14 years he was a hand-picked
by rick perry who worked under the trump
administration for the department of
energy very smart guy small business
owner
you can't imagine better candidates for
congress right now and our elections are
coming up that's why we're doing this
video right now because our primary
elections are coming up in early march
and so i want to get these two over the
finish line and you can support them at
texasreloaded.com well congressman i
still remember the first one that you
did in 2020 and it had ever it had
airplane explosions the whole thing so
it really is a good idea because it
sticks in people's memories what is it
like filming an ad like this and whose
idea was this
um
it's my idea uh these are these are
these are generally my idea
uh i i enjoy this kind of thing i'll
admit it's my idea
i like i like i like doing this sort of
creative direction kind of thing i mean
if you follow me you probably get a
sense for that of course already and
what's it like i mean look we we bring
in a a really professional crew to do
this so it does feel like you're on a
movie set because these guys usually use
the same crew over and over again we've
become friends
they're really all about the cause
they're awesome they're awesome people
and um they're usually working on on
much higher level productions tv shows
movies that kind of thing so they really
know what they're doing and it's it's
it's a fun thing you'd be surprised we
get it all done within a day
so you know the people editing this
stuff it takes them a long time but for
us it's actually it's not that much time
out of our day and and with
go ahead joey go ahead yeah you know
congressman real quick i just want to
say i love your edgy advertising
campaigning i think you do a great job
reaching people wesley and morgan are
great guys i've known them forever but i
just need to remind you it's not just
socialists that skip leg day i just kind
of need to throw that out there i've
seen the t-shirt and i appreciate it uh
but uh but it's not just socialists that
skip leg day all right
um
who else is
brian mast you can talk to him and guys
like me
oh yeah
congressman thank you so much for
joining us this morning we appreciate it
just covering a range without pictures
sorry i can't see you guys so now i'm
getting it
we hear you real black jokes all right
thanks congressman appreciate it